hello I Rachel bloom and today we're
gonna talk about the capture of Adolf
Eichmann so Israel's established in 1948
and Israel's like okay we need our Oh
CIA and so they formed the Mossad and
David ben-gurion who's the Prime
Minister is like I'm going through
appoint you ease our harem to be head of
Mossad and he saw her L is like awesome
we're gonna hunt down Nazi war criminals
cuz they're a lot of Nazis still like
chillin and the guy at the top of their
list is Adolf Eichmann who literally
planned the Holocaust so he saw her I
was like what's nail this get another
grid of the wall I go in moose who's
been hunted meanwhile Adolf Eichmann is
living in Argentina making like a new
alias he's like hmm what's an
Argentinean sounding name oh I know
Ricardo Klement good job Adolf I mean
Ricardo wink however his kids who were
there with him they're like well I'm
really attached to Eichmann it's like in
all my yearbooks like I'm just gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna keep it so the Eichmann
kids are stupid okay so in the
1950s Eichmann's son Klaus starts dating
this very nice girl Sylvia and she's
like Donnie I'm dating like the best guy
his name is Klaus Eichmann and he's like
that's weird my dog loves licking her
Bob my dog licks her vagina more than
any dog at school anyway so Sophia's
father Lothar Herman is like ha Eichmann
Eichmann viv I chose that name
[Music]
and soul arthur tips off the Mossad and
he's like my daughters dating a guy
named Klaus Eichmann like this might be
Adolph Eichmann this might be the son of
a dog like me and the Mossad is like we
need to check this guy out
then so they send operative star GT not
all of you were Holocaust survivors and
they're like you need to take pictures
of I can to make sure this is Agnes that
we're not just like capturing some poor
Argentinian too smart
okay so no what are you looking for like
water went under the Galvez I got you
yeah
thanks friend mm-hmm so they send a guy
who just kind of walks up to him while
he's gardening and they're like toes how
Ugandan and he's like well and he like
starts to explain gardening to them and
the whole time they have a suitcase that
has like a spy camera in it so they're
like and he's like what's that sound and
they're like nothing so they send the
pictures back to Israel and the Mossad
is like dudes this is Eichmann let's get
him there but how I was like well
Argentina is really bad about
extraditing not seized they like don't
give a for some reason I don't know
why I don't know why but they're just
bad about it and he tells V Hourani if
we're gonna capture it off like then
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
like full and kidnap like like a kid on
a milk carton we're gonna have to milk
carton Adolf like mm-hmm
so the four operatives they go to
Argentina it's weirdest health story
about Nazism be so cozy
anyway they Parker deserted Cardle or
Eichmann and they're like hey guys so it
to distract ourselves we need to come up
with your group name how about
the kidnapping friends and one of them's
like no I don't like that okay if we're
gonna come up with names now's not the
time to do it but if we're going to I
think it should be called the abduction
posse and another one's like no no no no
no no listen how about I don't know the
snatch squad and they're like snatch
squad and just then that's when Eichmann
walks down the road and they're like our
car is broken down psyche it's not and
they tackle like they just like full-on
like bum rush Eichmann and they kick him
in the car and my job continues to lick
road I'll be done I wanna do the rest of
story lying down you do it you do it you
you do it the way you want so they bring
him to a safe house and then they tried
to question him to make sure it's Adolf
Eichmann living in Germany all right
aren't you
and Eichmann's like hola me llamo
Ricardo Klement
like he's pretending to be Argentinian
they're just like clearly not you are a
pasty white German dude and finally he
drops all the he's like all right
I'm Adolph Eichmann can I get the glass
of wine no okay there's a plane leaving
from Buenos Aires to Israel how do we
sneak I commit onto this plane so may
20th 1960 they sedate Adolph Eichmann
they dress him up as an El Al flight
attendant which is the Israeli airline
and they literally like drag him to the
airport like full-on weekend at bernie's
ding the orchestrator of like the worst
thing that's ever happened in their
lives and just be like yeah I'm tired
hello I'm Anne Anne our flight attendant
and they're literally carrying him like
onto the plane
I mean like the stories being insane so
they I'm in Israel and they put Eichmann
on trial and he's convicted and he's
hung outside of Tel Aviv and the guys
who captured him are like look far be it
for we to celebrate death but also um
yeah the lousy the Nazis man I'm alive
I'm 97 for four Oscars
[Music]